trop nombreux les sangliers nuits STO
culture et équipement des villes des
villages le préfet d'Indre-et-Loire a
ordonné une battue administrative ce
jeudi suite à une alerte d'agriculteurs
de ballon Miré une quinzaine de
chasseurs et ont participé une opération
rendue nécessaire dans une zone
périurbaine où la chasse est d'ordinaire
interdite la battue a été suivie par
Faustine Luneau
chargez votre âme une fois que vous êtes
au poste et une fois que tout le monde
est installé en toute sécurité le
lieutenant de louveterie donne les
consignes de sécurité à Ballan-Miré ce
groupe de chasseurs s'apprête à réaliser
une battue administrative ordonnée par
le préfet d'Indre-et-Loire en cause un
trop grand nombre de sangliers
considérés comme une espèce susceptible
d'occasionner des dégâts c'est un
agriculteur qui a signalé une
prolifération de sanglier et ce qui a
donné suite à une saisie du préfet le
passage des sangliers endommage
régulièrement les cultures en
Indre-et-Loire la préfecture estime que
60% des dégâts qu'elle subissent se
réduit à la prolifération d'animaux
nuisibles et c'est aussi une source de
danger pour les automobilistes à
proximité nous avons une départementale
7 qui est très fréquentée et
régulièrement nous avons des des
voitures qui percutent les sangliers
parfois avec des accidents graves
contrairement à la chasse traditionnelle
une battue administrative peut avoir
lieu hors des périodes de chasse sur des
terrains privés et en zone périurbaine
ce qui rend la tâche plus compliquée les
conditions de tir sont très difficiles
sur le principe où il y a des maisons un
peu partout et il y a des choses il y a
des gens qui se promènent donc on est
vraiment un petit comité sur des zones
restreintes avec des tirs à courte
distance pour limiter les risques autour
de ballon mirer plus d'une soixantaine
de sangliers auraient été aperçus selon
des agriculteurs l'objectif de la battu
est donc des farouché ses sangliers
présents trop près des villes et dont
tuer quelques-uns pour éviter qu'ils ne
reviennent mais après plus de trois
heures de trac les chasseurs rentrent
bredouille les sangliers sont partis à
mon collège les chiens les gens n'ont
pas pu étirer donc on essaie de les
retrouver un peu plus loin mais on n'est
pas tomber dessus deux précédentes
battus avaient déjà eu lieu dans ce
secteur en décembre et en avril dernier
elles avaient donné lieu à l'élimination
de 16 sangliers